هل بدا فعلا الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد الذي
يترقبه العالم رئيس فاجنار يعلن عن تقدم
القوات الاوكرانيه على اطراف مدينه باخموت
اعلان ياتي بعد ساعات من تصريحات اعلاميه
للرئيس الاوكراني اكد فيها ان بحاجه الى
المزيد من الوقت
سيكون هجومنا المضاد اقوى بوصول بعض
الاسلحه اهم شيء هو حمايه شعبنا نتوقع
معدات مدرعه مناسبه نتلقى الاسلحه على
دفعات يمكن المضي قدما لكن لن نضمن نجاح
العمليه فقد نخسر الكثير من رجالنا واعتقد
ان هذا مستحيل نحن بحاجه للانتظار وبحاجه
الى المزيد من الوقت
تتجه الى باخموت التي تشهد اطول معركه منذ
بدء الغزو الروسي للاراضي الاوكرانيه على
الخطوط الاماميه مقاتل شركه فاجنر ينتقد
زعيمهم تاخر وصول الذخيره وقد هدد
بالانسحاب من المدينه
وعلى الجهه المقابله يستعد الجيش
الاوكراني وينتظر وصول الدعم العسكري تعول
عليه كياف لارغام القوات الروسيه على
التراجع وفي انتظار اعلان رسمي عن بدء
الهجوم المضاد تتواصل استعدادات طرفي نزاع
على عده جبهات